in the last video you saw how sampling a
random over the range of hyper
parameters can allow you to search over
the states of hyper parameters more
efficiently but it turns out that
sampling at random
doesn't mean something uniformly at
random over the range of valid values
instead it is important to pick the
appropriate scale on which to explore
the hyper parameters in this video I
want to show you how to do that let's
say that you're trying to choose the
number of hidden units n L for a given
layer l and let's say that you think a
good range of values is somewhere from
50 to 100 in that case if you look at
the number line from 50 to 100 maybe
picking some number of values at random
within this number line there's a pretty
reasonable way to search for this to
grow high parameter or if you're trying
to decide on the number of layers in
your network you're calling that capital
L maybe you think the total number of
layers should be somewhere between 2 to
4 then something uniformly random amount
2 3 & 4 might be reasonable or you've
been using a grid search where you
explicitly evaluate the values 2 3 & 4
might be reasonable so these were couple
examples were at something at uniformly
random over their range of contemplating
might be a reasonable thing to do but
this is not true for all hyper
parameters let's look at another example
say you're searching for the hyper
parameter alpha the learning rate and
let's say that you suspect 0.0001 might
be on the low end or maybe it could be
on as high as 1 now if you draw the
number line from 0.0001 to 1 and sample
values of random uniformly random over
this number line or you know about 90%
of the values you sample will be between
0.1 and 1 so you're using 90% of easels
is to search between 0.1 and one and
only 10% of the resources to search
between 0.01 and 0.1 so that doesn't
seem right
instead it seems more reasonable to
search for high preferences on the log
scale when instead of using a linear
scale you have zero point zero zero zero
one zero and then zero point zero zero
one zero point zero one zero point one
and then one and you instead sample
uniformly at random on this type of
logarithmic scale now you have more
resources dedicated searching routine
0.0001 and point zero one and between
0.01 and 0.001 and so on so in Python
the way you implement this is let R
equals negative four times MP dot random
dot band and then a randomly chosen
value of alpha would be alpha equals 10
to the power of r so after this first
line R will be a random number between
minus 4 and 0 and so alpha here would be
between 10 to the minus 4 and 10 to the
0 so 10 to the minus 4 is this left
things as 10 to minus 4 and 1 is 10 to
the 0 in a more general case they become
a sample between tenth of a - 10 to the
B on the log scale and in this example
this is 10 to the a and you can figure
out what a is by taking the log base 10
of 0.0001 we're going to tell you a is
negative 4 and this value on the right
this is 10 to the B and you can figure
out what B is by taking log base 10 of 1
which tells you B is equal to 0 so what
you do is then sample are uniformly
random between a and B so in this case R
would be C minus 4 and 0 and you can set
alpha on your randomly sample Hydra
parameter value as 10 to the arm okay so
just to recap to solve on the log scale
you take the low value take long to
figure out what is a take the high value
take a lot to figure out what is B
so you're now John the sample from 10 to
the a2 tends to be on a log scale so you
set are uniformly random between a and B
and then you set the hyper parameter to
be 10 to the R so that's how you
implement something on this logarithmic
scale finally one other tricky case is
something the hyper parameter beta use
for computing exponentially weighted
averages so let's say you're suspect
that beta should be somewhere between
zero point nine to zero point nine nine
nine you know maybe this is the range of
values you want to search over so
remember that when computing
exponentially weighted averages using
0.9 is like averaging over plus the last
ten values kind of like taking the
average of 10 days temperature whereas
using 0.99 is like averaging over the
last 1,000 values so similar to what we
saw on the last slide if you want to
search routine point 99.999 it doesn't
make sense example on the linear scale
right uniformly random between point
99.999 so a better way to think about
this is that we want to explore the
range of values of 1 minus beta which is
going to now range from zero point one
to zero point zero zero one and so we'll
sample the team beta taking values from
zero point one so maybe zero point one
since 0.001 so using the method we have
faded out on the previous slide this is
10 to the minus 1 this is 10 to the
minus 3 notice on the previous slide we
have the small value on the left and the
large value on the right but here we
have a reverse with the large value on
the left and a small value on the right
so what you do is you sample are
uniformly random from negative 3 to
negative 1 and you set 1 minus beta
equals 10 to the R and so beta equals 1
minus 10 to the R and this becomes a
your randomly sampled value of your
hyper parameter chosen on the
appropriate
and hopefully this make sense in that
this way you spend as much resources
exploring the range 0.14 in 0.99 to 0.99
so if you want to study more formal
mathematical justification for why we're
doing this right why is this such a bad
idea to sample on a linear scale it is
that when beta is close to 1 the
sensitivity of the results you get
changes even with very small changes to
beta so if beta goes from zero point
nine to zero point nine zero zero five
you know it's no big deal this is hardly
any change in your results but if theta
goes from zero point nine nine nine to
zero point nine nine nine to five this
will have a huge impact on exactly what
your algorithm is doing right in both of
these cases is averaging over roughly
ten values but here is gone from an
exponentially weighted average over
about one thousand of the last 1,000
examples so now the last two thousand
examples that is because that formula we
had 1 over 1 minus beta this is very
sensitive to small changes in beta when
beta is close to 1 so what this whole
sampling process does is it causes you
to sample more densely in the regime of
when beta is close to 1 or alternatively
when 1 minus beta is close to 0 so that
you can be more efficient in terms of
how you distribute the samples to
explore the space of possible outcomes
more efficiently so I hope this helps
you select the right scale or which the
sample high preferences increase you
don't end up making the right scaling
decision on some hyperthermic detroit
you know don't worry too much about even
your sample on a uniform scale where
some other scale would have been
superior you might still get ok results
especially we use a closed defined
search so that in later iterations you
focus in more on the most useful range
of hyper parameter values to sample I
hope this helps you with your high
performance research in the next video I
also want to share you some thoughts on
how to
organized your hypotonic research
process that I hope will make your
workflow a bit more efficient